Hello everyone.
This is Gavin and Dan.
Coming to you live from
inside the internet.
Except it's not live.
It's not live.
You see, prerecorded.
Yeah, we're doing a voice over.
We rarely do this but Dan
knows a lot about guns
and he wants to talk
about guns, don't you?
Little bit.
We're using a different
camera on this one.
It's the V1610.
It's the same camera we
used to shoot underwater.
That is incredibly slow.
This is at 18000 frames per second.
18000?
And you can count it.
You got one, two, three,
four cases in the air.
There's always like a tiny little ember
on the rim of the case.
Yeah, just flying out of it.
Look how the gun shakes.
Yeah, it's crazy.
It looks sturdy as hell.
Pretty rattley in slow mo.
You can even see when
we speed it up slightly
your watch is rattling
around on your wrist too.
Oh, yeah.
Pretty efficient machine.
Every movement is for a purpose.
Yeah, the firing pin
now is impacting on the
primer of the round.
That fires the bullet out and
the empty case gets ejected.
So it's being pulled backwards here
using the force of the gas
to pull the working part.
So there's nothing
actually pulling that back.
No.
It's just the force of
the bullet going out
that's ejected that.
It's the gases.
Yeah, that are being created.
And the next round gets loaded in
when the spring on the
other side sets itself,
extracting the next
round from the magazine.
I see the next round go up just there.
It gets loaded into the chamber
and then the firing pin again
impinges on the primer of the round.
That ignites the
propellant inside the round
and that causes the
gas to force the bullet
out the end of the barrel
and the case out the rear.
This is my favorite part finish firing.
Look how wide eyed you are there.
Oh, my God.
Your eyes.
Whoa.
Looks like you've seen a yeti.
Yeah, I went back quite a ways.
Yeah, you did crap yourself.
Yeah.
On the first shot.
You literally took a step back.
You're like.
Little bits of poo poo.
All right, so now's the part, Dan,
where I show you how its really done.
My first time ever
firing an assault rifle.
Especially automatic.
I think before this I'd
only ever fired a pistol
and a shotgun.
There we go, first shot.
First shot.
You can see my reaction time.
I haven't blinked yet.
The round's already been
fired by this point.
The round has already
probably gone through
and exited the target.
The rifle is pushing back
because you didn't have
it fully in your shoulder.
Well, I didn't have it in my shoulder,
but my lean was wrong.
I was leaning back.
There goes the eye.
I've already killed someone
and I'm just now blinking.
Yeah.
Still firing.
Still firing obviously,
I'm not going to let off the trigger.
Yeah, sure, yeah.
I'm not going to baby it.
Close your eyes.
Oh, nice little vent of gas there.
Yeah.
I'm going to speed it up
so you can see the amount that I've--
Not in control of that at all.
Well, I've never done it before.
Look it.
I was just told not to
let go of the trigger
so the rest of it was--
Well you did a good job of that.
So, now I'm thinking, right,
let's try and get this gun
back pointed towards the ground
while I'm trying to walk forwards again.
Because on the other camera,
I'm completely out of shot.
Yeah, yeah.
Now the gun has gone out of focus
but you can see some pretty
shots of the cases coming out,
which is pretty cool.
It's weird after you
get to the point where
you know what's going on
and you don't blink anymore.
Every single shot is
like, kow, kow, kow, kow.
But you just don't blink.
It gets to the point where
you're just used to what's going on.
Well, there's something called a keyhole
where when you're firing on automatic
your first shot goes on target,
the next one's slightly further up,
then slightly further up.
And then it comes back
round and down again
when you get it back under control
and you realize what's happening.
So, obviously you've got
like a huge keyhole there.
It's ridiculous isn't it really
that you're just hurling chunks of metal
and you're not even really
aiming where you want to be.
It's just like your body's not
good enough to fire this gun.
I can't not blink.
The first round is
always the most difficult
and that after that you
sort of get used to it.
All right well thank you
for watching our gun video.
Also thanks to Destin
from Smarter Everyday
for setting that shoot up.
That was while we were hanging out
with Destin in Alabama last year.
Had a lot of fun doing
it as well, so yeah.
Yeah, if you like gun stuff
be sure to check out his channel.
Also, check out the video we
did with underwater pistols.
Follow us both on Twitter.
My Twitter name is GAVINFREE.
Also happens to be my real name.
What about you, Daniel?
Mine is DANIELGRUCHY.
Again happens to be my real name.
Not gruchy.
Not grouchy.
No, none of those.
Gruchy, technically.